TJ Miller is the breakout star of HBO's
text at tire Silicon Valley stealing
scenes is the obnoxiously aggressive and
aggressively obnoxious Erlich Bachman I
know that you look at me and see a guy
who has it all figured out and for the
most part you're right you know half the
yogurts gonna go unused because one
quarter of the jam can't come out
he's hitting big at the movies too with
a major role as weasel in the
blockbuster Deadpool here's a look back
at where he might have seen Miller
before carpoolers
Miller's first major role came via the
short-lived ABC single-camera comedy
created by the kids in the halls Bruce
McCullough it followed the lives of four
guys connected only by their daily
carpool Miller played the son of one of
the carpoolers
a gigantic but soft-spoken man baby knee
Marmaduke who still lives at home
doesn't work and spends most of his time
entertaining his own flights of whimsy
hey Bob
father I'm no longer Bob although on
some level I did feel closer to you as
Bob there's just too many things going
on plan to be ignored Cloverfield very
little was known about Cloverfield
before it hit theaters including the
cast Miller plays a bro named hood and
this JJ Abrams produced found footage
style science fiction thriller about a
group of college-age friends having a
party in New York City until they're
terrorized by a Godzilla type monster
creature and its horrifying minions
while you don't see Miller's face
through most of Cloverfield that's only
because his character is the guy holding
the camera and narrating the movie the
whole time in the end though things just
don't work out too well for old hug
Chelsea Lately carpoolers was cancelled
after 13 episodes and the star of
Cloverfield was the monster
so Miller still had some career climbing
to do undaunted Miller turned to
stand-up and sketch comedy and made more
than three dozen appearances on Chelsea
Lately Chelsea Handler's talk show on e
showing up to do panel and also
appearing in sketches hey J I don't see
any stuffed animals well Brett I don't
know what to tell you okay I can't I
don't know what your prescription is I
don't know what you know what are you
doing it's a facial mist ever heard of
it he even guest hosted the show a few
times I mean have you ever seen
something like that little golden rhino
extract this comedy was written and
directed by my judge who also made
beavis and butt-head and office space
and is built around the owner of a
flavor extract company desperately
trying to cheat on his wife Miller plays
Rory a dim worker at the extract plant
what are we gonna do I got car payments
we're gonna take away my Geo they've
done it before we got to act fast it's a
bit part but it introduced Miller to
judge who would later cast him on
silicon valley Yogi Bear the 2010 big
screen version of Yogi Bear was meant to
appeal to kids largely ignorant of the
more than 50 year old cartoon character
the movies notable for Miller's
portrayal of Ranger Jones a role he
secured with an unhinged audition video
hey hey yogi what are you doing
yeah that's what I thought if you've
been stealing picnic baskets
you have why you've been told not to do
that where's boo boo oh well tell him to
come back here
Miller's that Warner Brothers a video of
himself dressed up like a ranger and
running lines with a bear he rented for
the day method acting at its finest
Ranger Smith I just wanted to say I'm
sorry I want to be in charge so bad that
no no hold on that the Goodwin games
during a short-lived Fox sitcom called
the Goodwin games Miller appeared as
lovable slacker Jimmy Goodwin through a
series of videos left by their late
father three estranged adult siblings
returned to their small town thinking
they're going to inherit their father's
Millions but it's really just a plot to
bring them closer together created by
Carter Bays and Craig Thomas who also
created How I Met Your Mother the
Goodwin games have its initial order cut
to just six episodes which aired in the
summer of 2013 transformers age of
extinction how do you know you've really
made it in Hollywood when your cast is
the comic relief in a Michael Bay action
movie okay okay okay all right
okay all right I was wrong and 2014
Miller appeared in transformers age of
extinction as Lucas Flannery mechanic
and best friend of Mark Wahlberg get in
here
lock that door doesn't have a lock well
it's kind of a tall order to compete
with dinosaur robots and a metal samurai
Miller still managed to offer some
stand-up moments of course that made his
characters death by Robo grenade all the
more tragic
the crunchies also called the Oscars of
Silicon Valley the tech industry hands
out awards to itself at each year's
crunchies because of his role on Silicon
Valley my wife picked acai then you
married poorly Miller was asked to host
in 2015 and organizers thought he'd
bring some fun to the proceedings
bring him does he not have a way to come
tell him to get an uber he did but he
also spent a lot of time making fun of
Gabby Holt's worth a violinist who plays
tech industry parties who is also the
girlfriend of uber founder Travis
kalanick
Holt's Worth and Miller got into a
shouting match and Miller made some
ill-advised comments before moving on to
mock the many venture capitalists in the
audience come on get into it act like
you made it thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which TJ Miller appearance is your
favorite